so today I'm going to show a game I play
before you were born two years ago and
it was played the Chess Club upstairs
and I beat yes can help you oh yeah
that's right
hi so well we got so we had some older
people in the class today in fact
there's more adults in this room than
kids so I hope you're a kid at home
because otherwise they're very
suspicious okay anyway and something
needs to like get a bandage for her head
because yeah come on in
the rooms fine all right welcome to
Pokemon class
I'm glad you entered yeah okay so we're
going to talk about a theme that most of
you don't know
it's called overworked okay for example
let's say you start at 8:00 in the
morning and you finish 11:00 p.m. you're
overworked right
sometimes your pieces are doing too much
right you're like oh my Knights
defending this and this and this again
do all that stuff come on okay so if
you're a security guard and you are okay
and you have a job that's from 8:00 a.m.
to noon and you have another job from
8:00 a.m. to noon how do you go to both
jobs easy sends your clones with the
other one in fact you can have clones of
both of them and then stay at home get
two paychecks that way come on think
outside of the box for once all right so
this game there was a lot of overworked
and in fact not only did i trick my
opponent even tricked me once with
overwork I can't even believe it was
higher rated than me okay
so we played your favorite opening other
than Paul Meacham what's the name of
this opening I know he knows uh you
NIMS Oh Indian riot and that was named
after the famous Grandmaster Indian you
nimzowitsch what was his first name Oh
II didn't know that one
now that was his last name yeah wait how
do you know that
you feelin all right yeah man somebody
had their Wheaties today
okay so aron nimzowitsch the
nimzo-indian if we call the nimzowitsch
Indian that would take too long and
we're lazy around here all right now
when I was 14 years old I did something
you've never heard of I played in a
correspondence tournament where you mail
somebody your move and they're like aha
then they mail you back a move the game
takes about a year and a half
I'm not kidding that wasn't a joke where
he can back me up over there yeah Paul
backs me up they don't do that now
because of the internet when I was a kid
there was no internet then Al Gore came
along and we were all set okay so in a
correspondence game I had the black
pieces and my opponent played here and
they beat me like I didn't know how to
play at all there was a good reason for
that I didn't know how to play at all
and after my opponent beat me I said I'm
going to play that move and so not only
did I play that move I went to the
t-shirt shop this isn't even a joke and
I got a t-shirt that said Queen c2
exclamation mark okay and you probably
heard that at home because I touch the
mic so Ben's going crazy over there he's
like what's going on okay and I've been
playing Queen sheets you ever since and
then I'll play the dims only with black
anymore
I'm the worst okay so my opponent
attacked my pawn because he's mean
my queen was here defending my pawn now
it's not there
so my pawn is attacked so the first
thing I did was
now I cried okay the second thing I did
was I take yum-yum-yum-yum-yum okay if
it's free it's for me
my opponent agreed he took the pawn now
I like to pin things as you can see I
pinned this microphone up here nobody
helps mented all by myself right yeah
because we're both named Ben so it
doesn't count
all right now if I pin is Knight am
notice how his Knights pinned because I
said so so if his Knight moves I'll take
his Queen that moves the worst move ever
and I'm really old so I've seen every
move okay now black has a really good
trick and you'll like it because tricks
are for kids so the adults will like it
he can sacrifice his bishop check that
he can check me again
see how it's check and then when my King
moves away he'll take my bishop no so
did I do that and lose the game is that
what I did no Arjun you didn't like that
what it's your birthday come on sure up
all right
so I played Knight here and he played
night there and then I pinned his knight
now my knight vicious protected hooray
okay and he attacked my bishop that
wasn't very nice so I moved it
then he castled and I moved my bishop
let's see where did my bishop go hmm oh
yeah I went here is that a good move
you guys aren't grandmasters so you
can't jump over pieces yet no no so I
played here now he unpinned his Knight
that wasn't very nice now I can't pin
his Knight to his queen okay now where
did this guy go I forgot where'd he go
nowhere what is he a beetle he's a real
Nowhere bishop living in his nowhere
okay so b6 now his bishop has some
possibilities and he moved to one of
them now none of you have ever heard
this before so you're good
you really shocked rooks belong on open
files yeah I know okay
an open file has no pawns and if there's
no pawns then rooks can move up and down
just like the Clippers will move up and
down the court today okay
beating the the hapless Houston Rockets
right Arjun all right so this is the
open file it's the only one that white
has no pawns every other file White has
pawns files go up and down and they have
letters that's the D file okay
what's the most famous file the correct
answer is as Paul will tell you the
Rockford Files that's the most famous
file so I played rook to the D file he
played his rook to the open file that
wasn't very nice then I played my other
rook to the oh but wait I can't do that
darn I'll keep trying you guys can wait
a little while man doesn't think I'm a
grandmaster
hold on maybe if I like do this no all
right so I move this guy off and then
this guy I'll go here later right okay
now he was afraid I was going to go
Knight here and take the pawn what a
chicken okay so he stopped my knight
from going here because he's mean how
did he do that yes a six but I went
there anyways I'm great no I didn't go
there all right now we're going to do
overworked number one I don't know how
many there are probably about seven this
is number one this bishop is overworked
it's defending the knight on f6 and the
pawn on d6 so I took the knight on f6
BAM
if he takes with the bishop then yummy
yummy yummy yummy yummy a free pawn
notice my rooks are protecting each
other because I said so
so is that what he did did he give you a
free pawn
no he took with the pawn right now I
wanted this pawn but it's defended a few
times so I attacked it again with what
move and e4 right ok now he overworked
me he took me out back and over that's
working me over that's one of them ok
he played nine to be for attacking my
queen because he's a meanie and he
unleashed and the pawns that's a fork
and he unleashed his Bishop on my knight
that wasn't very nice of him okay so I
called the director the doctors like can
I help you and I said my opponents not
very nice so they gave him a timeout and
then Arjen gave me a KitKat the end when
did a good story that's driving Auto
sense did that story make any dollars or
just sons right this game was played in
India so made rupees right no I was
played upstairs okay
so I played Queen b1 and I started
walking around trash-talking I was like
I'm defending this and I'm defending
this you got nothing you're all talking
a badge that's why I told him then he
saw the movie Untouchables and he
understood what I was saying amazing
right
if you're Robert De Niro's watching this
don't sue me you with some crazy comment
that's not crazy at all although it's
not good 9 takes a to eventually if you
play nine takes a two now then I go BAM
okay and then I get to keep my
Grandmaster title because now white
threatens everything the rook on CA the
bishop on b7 the knight on a 2 right but
he did it the opposite way because it
was opposite day instead of night a2 and
I'll show you what your idea was because
your idea was really good you were
hoping I would take and then you were
going to take my knight and laugh at me
whatever do to you but as Arjun will
point out he instead played
Bishop takes e4 I'm afraid to make this
move because alright don't mess up
because I'm a nice guy
alright now I was like thank you then he
was like thank you now I'm down upon
when you play chess is that where you
want your knight
no okay what would a karo Nakamura say
he would say terrible just terrible okay
right well I say that too
okay now if his knights over there I
better check made him I don't think his
knights protecting his King too good in
fact I don't think anything's protecting
his King too good so I played nine to d4
and I was going to fork over here okay
and now he was like I don't want you to
fork over there I called the director I
said he's talking during the game okay
and it wasn't a kid's tournament so he
couldn't so he played night here his
knight defends and his Knights not
really silly over here now we have over
works number three okay number one I did
number two he did that's my turn my turn
right okay you see his pawn on f7 the
one I'm highlighting okay that's
defending this pawn so I can't take air
it's stopping me from checking him
because they'll take so his pawn is
doing too much so I took the pawn anyway
notice how it Forks his Queen and rook
so he made the obvious move takes my
knight and then I give him a check
okay and he knew me so he knew that
check was going to bounce so he didn't
accept that okay don't tell the IRS okay
my name is Ben Simon if you're the IRS
okay and I don't know student loans
anymore yes he even though the story of
your life all right so here he made the
worst move ever terrible moving is King
in the corner what a bad move right
it's the only move right okay then I
checked and then I checked all right now
if this was bughouse
I'd play rook h7 beat and Queen g7 made
and everything made but it's not bug
house this is real life sir eventually
if I play Queen h6 you may be correct
okay and the only thing I want to draw
as a picture I don't want to draw this
game now if I'm going to checkmate him I
need more pieces sir it's coming give me
a second so I played Bishop to g4 and
I'm going to take this guy and that's
going to be checkmate also take his rook
so he defended his pawn with Queen to d7
okay now I played Bishop f5 threatening
checkmate he played the obvious move
take now we get back to your answer your
answer and one of you yeah what was your
answer rugby for now when this pawn was
here he could go there and his Bishop
stops work h4 now he can't do that
because it's cheating
so his bishop can't defend h4 here comes
Rick h4 mate I'm down to pieces but his
King doesn't look so good maybe it needs
like a dress or something you know put
some makeup on and that King would look
good right now terrible getting
checkmated okay so he gave up with a1 no
that's not what happened he didn't want
to get checkmated so he blocked my rook
did I jump over checkmate I'm a
grandmaster of course I did okay
I took threatening me and he's like no
if you go here I'm going to take your
rock okay
it but I got two rooks one for each of
them the movie tombstone don't sue me
okay so how did I attack h4 again yes
rook GD for I thought you were
stuttering but you're right okay rook GD
for now I'm going to play rook h4 and
meet him oh alright now when the game
ended I said excuse me sir
but you should have played this smooth
and he was like say what in the game he
played Queen d8 so his Queen and Bishop
protect h4 that move loses and I said
dude you should have played here and he
was like what and the idea is check and
now his rook and Queen protect each
other you see what I'm saying if his
rook was in there this would be
checkmate but as Rick is there now I go
here for King his queen and night even
that's not a queen it's a ruck but I was
close okay then he saves his rock I
don't know here and I get a knight
well I thought I did it seems to me that
white his three pawns ahead I have six
pawns and he has three right so I he
said but White's winning here and I said
I know so he doesn't like this because
he's losing what he did was more losing
he got the prize for the most losing it
was actually a million dollars yeah at
least two kids believe me and at home
they're like wow I could lose it with a
million dollars if you don't believe me
ask Anand BAM anybody Carl sit on
nothing you incorrect no okay so maybe
okay so he didn't play rook c7 I told
you what he played but it was one minute
ago who remembers Arjun Queen d8 now
lucky for me if I put my rook on the H
file it's checkmate
Darcy agrees
yeah so if I play rook h4 he stopped all
that where else can I put my rook hold
on okay not Arjun
I played rook F 3 and then rook age 3
mate is coming ok now he didn't want me
to play rook h3 mate because my other
rook and take his bishop let's see he
makes a silly move that's silly
Shaq Chuck me okay so he didn't want to
get made it because he was a 2,700
Grandmaster he decided that would be bad
for his rating so he played F Foyle
well after he after he didn't play 8 a 5
I mean okay can I jump over that now all
right
this is over work number 4 and the best
one this is the best overworked even
Paul will be impressed earlier he was
like look horrible right he was leaving
in mad going to throw you and crying
getting more and more Froyo ok writing
letters what I look at this terrible
lecture but now finally he will be
impressed even though he's already seen
the game right yeah he's like I forgot
what he didn't know all right so the
reason he's not getting checkmated is
his Queen and Bishop are defending so if
I check then he'll block right ok but
his Queen and Bishop are also defending
this pawn that's overworked he's
stopping me and he's protecting a pawn
which is more important that's a tough
question
mate or upon me so I want him to move
his pieces away from the mate defense so
what did I do
Arjen rook takes d6 ok then for some
reason lots of trash-talking commenced
right the Arjun is always like
trash-talking and I'm like dude you got
to stop that right yeah ok
he's been trash talk over 73 years
right true story right hi now if he
takes my rock
then checkmates good for me because you
win when you check me right yeah he
likes that he like a checkmate okay well
soon so he played Bishop h4
now this isn't checkmate is it right so
I put him in check here or here hmm here
here I put h6 is better I don't want to
beat him too badly he'll cry okay then I
checked him again then I checked him
again now this is very funny I thought
it was funny you may disagree I went to
my computer and I said what should black
play
what's the best move right the computer
said Queen f6 is the best move right man
when Queen f6 is the best move you
probably should take up golf or
something I so he played King e7 and I
played jack now he did something you've
never done before
he thought for four minutes that was the
longest thing of the game now let me ask
you a really hard math question nobody's
ever solved it
how many legal moves does black have
yeah one and he's 2,700 do you think he
saw it so why do you think for four
minutes yeah yeah he saw so he thought
for four minutes because he was thinking
about like what happened and they gave
up until that point and he wasn't happy
about that he prefers winning to losing
you know what I mean
okay so he did the obvious thing and it
wasn't King d7 even at Richard Nixon fan
in here yeah he gave up now let's
pretend he didn't give up because
pretending is fun let's pretend he went
here now White has maton too and there's
two answers so you could find one of
them you
RUP d6 is very close you're 2/3 right
what's 2/3 of Rick d6 yeah that is 2/3
of Rick g6 but I wasn't thinking of it
but you're right
I was thinking Queen d6 but yeah you're
you're right - Queen b6 I recommend this
move and then me or as Arjen pointed out
Rick d4 now I have a different math
question how many different King moves
is black have yeah yeah good answer yeah
zero is correct so the only possible
move is here solid then me so instead of
playing King d7 and giving me my choice
of checkmates he gave up now when
grandmasters lose are they really mad
and grumpy the answer is yes but he was
and he was all happy okay what kind of
hair to do was that he was like me and
you crushed me so I gotta tell you a
funny story which you kids won't care
about but you at home will find it funny
when I lived in Europe before you were
born I used to watch sugar because that
was the only thing on TV so you want me
to do
now there was darts - okay and in
snooker
it's very strange rules it's like pool
but it's more difficult and the highest
score you can get is either 147 or 148
but since it's been 25 years I forgot
it's one of them and you have to play
perfect and always hit the highest ball
in any way a guy did it on TV he got the
highest score and when it ended they
reminded me of this game when he got the
highest score ever and he won he jumped
into his opponents arms and they hugged
yeah because it was like the greatest
thing ever and his opponent was
impressed usually when somebody beats
you you're like her he was like wow
you're the greatest okay that's sort of
what happened in this game he was like
wow you played great okay whenever I
lose a chess game I told my opponent
congratulate
you're the best right however since I
never lose I have to say that too often
right he's like wait a minute that
doesn't make any sense
yeah wait okay sometimes when people
lose their like or now Paul never loses
he wins every tournament he plays in he
doesn't know what I'm talking about
but if he ever does lose a game he'll be
very gracious right is that what you
kids do when you lose you're like good
game you guys are the best right that's
the right attitude okay there's only one
thing better than losing a game and
being gracious about it what is it yeah
now I'm like the second best community
in this room you wait a minute that
answer is better than mine now you're
talking all right now remember when you
beat somebody really bad just before you
checkmate them you get in your car you
drive to the store you buy a microphone
you come back you checkmate them you
drop the microphone and you leave you
got that make sure you do that next time
right that'll work out real well for you
what man some of them you know I was
telling one of my six year old students
12 years ago he's not six anymore I said
you gotta learn how to trash talk okay
and then when I left he asked his mom
mom how do I trash talk
right that's like you ask your mother
trash talk man but he really did learn
how to trash talk
and now he's 2470 rated so guess what he
knows how to trash he still doesn't
crash talk